And now the moment you've all been waiting for
marvel studios black widow enjoy this special look
i've lived a lot of lives but
i'm done running from my past
there was an assassin spy an avenger
before then i had a family on july 9th we have
unfinished business we fight with you the wait
is over
you okay great plan i love the
part that i almost bled to death
i'm done running for my past
who the hell is that guy
why do you guys do that thing do what the thing
you do when you're fighting and then like the
there's this thing that you do and you look
good when you're fighting with the arm and
the hair and you do like a fighting pose it's
a it's a fighting pose you're a total poser
it still fits
oh my god
i never washed it once come and drink
family back together hmm again as our family
construct was just a calculated rules that
only lasted three years i don't think that we
can use this this term anymore can we oh great
so here's what's gonna happen okay reunion then
huh and uh i want to say something right off the
bat you haven't aged that day huh you're just as
beautiful and as supple as the day they
staged our marriage you got fat but still good
Welcome back everyone this is going to be my new
black widow trailer video marvel released a ton
of new footage for the movie i believe this
is part of their plan to release the entire
movie in like a hundred short two minute clips
between now and when it lands on disney plus
so be sure to subscribe to get all the videos
i will be doing regular easter egg videos for
the movie and it is coming out on disney
plus at the beginning of july but you will
be able to go see it in a movie theater if
you do want to see it in a movie theater
but while i'm talking about this footage also talk
about the falcon and winter soldier connections
because we learned about some deleted scenes or
some original plans for certain characters from
falcon and winter soldier with big cameos that
were supposed to happen during the black widow
movie but interestingly enough it starts with
julie louis dreyfus's valentina character madame
hydra val the contessa whatever you want to call
her after the falcon winter soldier finale the
producer said that originally her character was
supposed to debut during the black widow film now
they didn't say exactly what she was going to be
doing it sounds like it was going to be something
similar but apparently they were just going to
introduce her with a similar type of scene that
we saw her on falcon and winter soldier where she
introduces herself as a very mysterious figure
but she seems very powerful but kind of sinister
at the same time and she's putting together this
squad this team of anti-heroes or villainous type
characters we're not going to need captain america
for some of this stuff we're going to need a
u.s agent like we see full-blown u.s agent at
the end of the series so after falcon and winter
soldier everyone was thinking that she would be
tied to thunderbolts in the mcu and that was
what they were implying throughout the series
so given that she was originally supposed
to appear during the black widow film
maybe that has something to do with taskmaster or
yalana bulova at some point like maybe originally
she was going to show up at the end of that film
in present day when the film sort of jumps forward
in the timeline to after the events of avengers
end game and you find out what's happening with
the characters after the events of the black widow
film like at some point they have to find out that
natasha died on vormir so even though most of
the film takes place in the past before she died
some of the film will probably jump forward in
the timeline to after the events of endgame but
that's meant to be the falcon and winter soldier
connection speaking of taskmaster though there's
a whole lot more footage in these trailers
of taskmaster and another black widow shout
out to who is that guy so i will address all the
taskmaster theories because especially in this new
footage it does seem like there's enough evidence
to answer most of those taskmaster questions
there's also a separate character actor who you
haven't seen in any of these trailers yet played
by ot fagbenle called mason there's an important
reason why you haven't seen him in the trailers
yet either that i'll explain but also you could
probably tell what they've done with some of this
footage the last couple of months is polished it
up even more i think if you go back to my original
black widow trailer video the very first one from
like 10 years ago i think it was like 10 years ago
when they released the first trailer it seems
like it's been 10 years they also added a ton
more special effects and visual effects for the
black widow stingers one of black widow's biggest
trademark weapons in the comics is her black widow
sting it's an energy blast that just incapacitates
people like poison from a black widow spider you
get the reference you can thank stan lee for that
but that's what the special red vials are for in
the trailer i think early on a lot of people were
wondering what these vials were supposed to be
if it was connected to the super soldier serum
plot because of the falcon and winter soldier
connection weapons plus and then trying to remake
a new version of the serum but the vials are just
meant to be fuel for the stinger weapons as you
can see across the trailer like taskmaster uses
it too he's got a big one in that scene when he's
chasing them down and he copies some of hawkeye's
moves shooting the bow he uses it to detonate the
gas tank in the bmw suv that she and yelena belova
are trying to escape in it's all happening during
that big chase scene relatively early in the movie
when she first goes back to budapest everyone
posts all the budapest jokes in the comments
what happens in budapest stays in budapest
she goes back there to find and recruit yelena
belova for the mission to destroy what's left of
the black widow program then they get attacked by
the new black widows led by taskmaster after which
this scene probably happens where she asks yelena
about who that dude was like who is that guy and
yelena explains what's happened to the black widow
program how they've reinstated it the taskmaster
is kind of in charge but underneath drake off here
like the drake off's daughter reference from the
first avengers movie they'll pay off at easter
egg too but essentially they're brainwashing
these new women even more to make them better
killing machines making them more controllable
kind of like the clones on star wars that also
kind of makes you think of winter soldier with
the hydra commands too even though technically the
black widow program isn't directly connected to
hydra the black widow program was just from the
soviet government the russian government hydra
was doing their own thing with their own cell
of super soldiers the winter soldier was a part
of but after they get attacked by taskmaster here
that's probably when they go to get help from red
guardian to break him out of this siberian prison
in all the trailers we've seen them attacking
this big facility when she's in that white costume
from the comics then they go back to melina's farm
where she's been living all these years so that's
where they're at in all these other family based
scenes here too when they're sitting around the
dinner table this is melina's house she said that
all these years since the flashbacks that take
place during the film she's actually been raising
pigs experimenting on them so she's kind of a
scientist when she's not busy being a black widow
but she herself grew up as a black widow just
like natasha did interested in the fake family
that they created when they were in a sleeper cell
in america she was the mother red guardian was
the father like they had that other funny scene
when they start getting all sexy with each other
and natasha and yelena start getting grossed out
and taking all those shots like i'm going to have
to drink so much to block out this memory the
funny thing too is that rachel vice just did a big
interview where she talked about her character her
real name is molina vostakov in the movie but she
said that it was supposed to be a big secret about
what her last name was because i think they didn't
want people to easily be able to identify her as
iron maiden from the comics because that's who
molina vostikov is and she's kind of a black widow
villain so i think that's when people started to
make all the big taskmaster theories there were
a lot of people after that got out that were
assuming that she was going to secretly be the new
taskmaster but here's the thing there are a couple
other scenes later in this new trailer footage
that imply that she is not taskmaster so the way
they cut it is all over the place just meant to be
kind of confusing but if you look at a couple key
scenes here for instance you have this big black
widow versus taskmaster fight scene where they're
falling through the air and then after they hit
the ground you see taskmaster whip out their
sword from the comics but in another scene you see
that molina also standing amidst this rubble in
her white black widow uniform then you also see
her piloting the plane as it's crashing earlier
in this scene while red guardian is in the back of
the plane fighting taskmaster throwing his shield
at him captain america style so it just seems like
they're implying the taskmaster is not molina it's
someone else that's why early on a billion years
ago at the black widow comic con panel remember
how many years ago that was they were hyping
him up like he was an important character but
then you never saw him in any of the trailers
they even gave him his own poster but still
no trailer footage of any scenes of any kind with
him so it just seems like they're trying to avoid
giving away some big twists with his character
and the early theory is that he is taskmaster
but here's the deal he's also supposed to be
playing a separate character in the movie called
mason and he's supposed to be black widow's
version of q to make a james bond reference
like her contact where she goes to get all of her
supplies and weapons from and it's implied that he
has a romantic relationship with her or had one
at some point in the past so if he is taskmaster
secretly it would also still be a big betrayal
for her which i think is what they're going for
like whoever taskmaster really is is supposed to
be someone who was close or is close with natasha
so that when they do the face reveal it winds
up hitting that much harder like taskmaster face
reveal at 10 million subs you won't believe who
this is oh it's the dude that you've been sleeping
with this whole time after the hulk took off to
the car shocking twist but then they have that
other brand new scene of y'all in a bulova making
fun of natasha for her superhero landing pose like
your total poser i'm not a poser just making fun
of some of the more comic booky things that they
had natasha doing in the avengers movies like why
are you doing that when you're fighting that's
actually terrible fighting pose you'd actually get
taken out immediately if you did something like
that in a fight but there'll be some more black
widow stuff happening when we get a little closer
to the movie coming out and it's going to overlap
with the loki episodes next big thing obviously is
this week loki episode 1 is dropping so my full
episode video for that will post on wednesday
i also just posted my early non-spoilery
review so i'll link that at the end of this
congratulations rodrigo abro you're the giveaway
winner for my last big marvel video please email
me on the about page of my channel so i can get
your contact details everyone click here for that
loki episode 1 video and click here for my brand
new thor 4 love and thunder first look teaser
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight!